we can say anything we can say men ain't
[__] we can say men are trash we can say
I don't date short guys I don't date fat
guys I don't date broke guys nobody bats
an eye but if a man says I don't want a
girl with a kid I don't want to grow
that's obese I don't want a girl that is
ugly people are up in arms and then we
have body positivity [__] shaming I
don't want a hoe cause men are so oh
with it what do you mean with it girls
are out with it but there are songs
written about it because men I don't
want no scrubs
what if there is what if there's a hit
song what if there was a hit song called
I don't want no fat chicks like it would
not be the same they couldn't do it they
couldn't make number one yeah that's
what I'm saying but a girl but a but a
girl can say I don't want no scrubs and
that's that's a that's a Bop I mean
don't get me wrong I'll shim you to it
yeah all right it's a Bop